[Music]
on a cold night about three years ago in
a small office space I sat around
huddled around the computer with my
startup colleagues in deep anticipation
we had just launched the downloadable
version of an operating system that we'd
started it enabled you to put your
Android mobile apps on a desktop and
experience it we wondered if people
would use this product in different
countries around the world within a week
we had over 1 million people in over 180
countries use this product eventually it
was integrated into Chrome OS which is
used by hundreds of millions of people
how group of entrepreneurs was not here
in Silicon Valley nor in the United
States we were in the developing country
we were in Beijing China and that really
inspired me when I looked back on that
night because I myself from a developing
country you see 10 years ago I moved
from my home country of Zimbabwe to
China initially is planning to spend one
year learning how to read write and
speak Mandarin when I landed in China
and saw the remarkable innovation that
was there I decided that that was the
place that had to be and I said to
myself Towanda you need to stay here in
China to make that happen and be part of
it you see the image I had in my mind of
innovation was unit Packard in the Palo
Alto garage a few miles from here making
technology that would start in Silicon
Valley and trickle down to the rest of
the world and the world is changing this
used to be the place where this used to
be the only place we could get
opportunities to start an innovative
tech company what I realize is that
genius is equally this
tributed but opportunity is not there
was genius in Hungarian boy who survived
the Holocaust and a communist
dictatorship to come to the United
States and become the founding CEO of
Intel and the greatest manager in a
generation Andy Grove there was genius
in a Russian Jewish boy whose family was
persecuted in the 1970s and came here to
seek refuge and eventually co-founded
Google Sergey Brin there was genius in a
South African dreamer who came here
dropped out of his Stanford PhD in two
days and eventually co-founded PayPal
becoming today one of the boldest and
most iconic entrepreneurs Elon Musk
even in Steve Jobs whose father moved
here from Syria countless Chinese and
Indian entrepreneurs and engineers have
been the bedrock of talent in Silicon
Valley for the last few decades because
this was the only place where you could
find opportunity to build a great tech
company genius is equally distributed
but opportunity is not yet again the
world is changing more and more Springs
of innovation are rising up and black
places of the world that used to be
deserts of poverty and backwardness
we're able to see that over the next few
years the next billion people coming
online for the first time are not going
to be in Western Europe or in North
America they'll be in emerging markets
throughout Asia Africa and Latin America
will see a huge middle-class emerging
from raw as people migrate from rural to
urban areas to this mega cities in
Jakarta Indonesia and Delhi India and
thar Paulo Brazil as well as Lagos
Nigeria in all these places many
talented people will be able to stay at
home and build the entrepreneurial
dreams that they could only build here
we look as well at how ideas and crop up
in the most unexpected of places
growing up in Zimbabwe it is very clear
that we would save on gas by sharing
rides with each other we would invite
strangers into our cars so that they
would be able to hop in the ride and
give us a small amount of money and
together we'd bring down the overall
cost of the ride this is commonplace in
my country over a decade ago an American
entrepreneur named Logan green visited
Zimbabwe saw that this is the way that
we got around and was inspired to come
back to the United States and launch
Zimride a startup that provided a
carpooling service for students who at
the end of the school year could share
rides to go home this team and idea
evolved into lift the ride-sharing
application that many of us use and this
this industry of more than hundreds of
billions of dollars best taken over the
world
just by show of hands how many of us
have used ride has used lyft or uber
over the last month honey how many of us
knew that the idea was germinated in a
small southern African country not as
many as I thought Yeah right
as we can see ideas crop up in the most
unexpected of places a couple of years
ago I had the fortune of working with
many entrepreneurs who realized the
unique opportunities that come in
emerging markets I ran a startup
accelerator called Beijing tech hive
that's invested in early-stage
entrepreneurs in the mobile internet
these entrepreneurs were able to see
that in this world that we live in a new
paradigm of making products for and with
users needs to come into place it was in
May it was by a Chinese entrepreneur
that one of the most popular u.s.
apps for teenagers today tik-tok was
started it required someone who realized
what it really means to be mobile first
to have never had another product but
you have never had a desktop or laptop
as the only channel to the Internet
our world is changing much my
faster than we realize in parts of the
world that we used to say lacked
opportunity they'll continue to be ways
that entrepreneurs regardless of where
they are can make a new future and
create new innovation for us
I don't dare say that Silicon Valley is
no longer the preeminent center of
innovation in the world it is otherwise
I wouldn't be here and there's no
question that the United States has
created one of the greatest engines of
starting nurturing a businesses that the
world has ever known but we're able to
see that different parts of the world
are launching other opportunities and
hotbeds of innovation that continue to
be there and we have a choice to make we
can continue to over invest in highly
expensive startups that can't even
afford the garage as those
hewlett-packard entrepreneurs were able
to do or we could direct our capital to
parts of the world that desperately need
just that to take advantage of their
genius and their innovate in their
innovation we could continue to believe
that all great ideas will come from this
rich ecosystem a Stanford Silicon Valley
in the United States all we could
realize that if we open our minds and
our intellectually humble that more and
more ideas can spring out of these
places it is after all at a time now
today when we celebrate Apple pay and
Android pay as the latest innovation and
payments that we realized that it was in
over a decade and a half ago that in
East Africa where we lacked traditional
banking branches to provide to our rural
communities we had no option but to
leapfrog to mobile banking which is now
commonplace we have an opportunity to
open our minds to opportunities and
ideas that come from places
there are traditionally despised and
consider this backward if you are a
dreamer or an innovator regardless of
where you are you can in this world
that's highly connected start something
right from scratch the era of
trickle-down technology is over thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]